[Applause]
oh did that go in it's for dicks all
over if y'all get too
amp nice spin move back to his right
hand cancer a little bit too late how
about that just really hits up
basketball five Marcus smart he's come
on the floor and really has done a nice
job of getting himself as ball it's a
one-point affair right now tre young tre
here with a no-look bounce pass in
traffic John Collins the recipient
Trey's floater rims in what again
DeAndre Jordan he will not come up to
help because he's afraid of the pass to
John Collins Maps bench has outscored
Atlantis 28 to to young
[Applause]
20 tonight betray young now so 8 dodge
these look pretty good tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
but Lucan could fall in love with that
three ball all day long
[Music]
ray puts up the floater over deandre
again you see where Jordan is so far
back in the lake
leading up to seven young inside back to
the groove Alex you don't want to give
up quick asking under four to play
a clear path to the basket layup is good
a five-point lead Davis's Dale wants
time young been living in the paint this
whole second half right there over the
bigger Kevin knock some tough little
corner shots in the lane
gets away moon comes right back at
mudiay and a chance for a three-point
play now you need another stop after
that murdered three strange on gets it
all the way to the basket store for a
couple of weeks
crayons
never miss three-pointer that'll be
three had a 31 Trey young scoots in for
an easy school here's a pocket moving it
out Dorsett
[Applause]
right hundred seventeen Trey controlling
at Fitchburg Wow
[Applause]
like Nick Marietta Sandy Springs know
that CJ has nine and he got so excited
there's one of those little air
[Music]
so by his hairs jumped out on this
screen much fish long three by young
dango and he'll pose brilliantly
[Applause]
young with a quick step back down it
goes
and he'll get the four-point opportunity
handle the ball he uses his screen
really well and just a little step back
right there and a lot of times the
smaller guys they're tough to defend
because their center of gravity is so
low to the ground gets the switch home
standing is Brown young to the step back
three and another deep strike from Craig
y'all frisky spin off the glass to the
left
young sneaks it green just to feel
comfortable proud standing
[Applause]
LeBron James
[Applause]
tre young a nice Drive there it takes
the bump by LeBron off the glass and in
[Applause]
tre on a nice drive there it takes the
bump by LeBron off the glass and in
[Applause]
cherry pick oh geez oh gee
[Applause]
Wow
so Trey Young has now dribble between
two guys leg brave Bruce brown guarding
Trey brown has five pounds Trey driving
scoring and then it goes up 122 to 118
songs by three what a shot
Trey
[Music]
he shot just one from the parking lot
it's the bottom of the neck
last night Trey had five threes against
the Pistons great gets it back drives
past Lopez
that's a done deal tray with seven six
trains going to launch from deep it
looks like yep there it comes
[Applause]
in water check it out
you gotta make them go to the basket
again a little bit too much room we saw
developing we knew it was coming
[Music]
look at it again here
close out to 15 left washed out five
tray in the pen tray
get it off Collins pick and roll tray
with a long drive that's good what was
JJ reading joy Turner looks blades it
into tray two seconds watch race flutter
[Applause]
to say
deserve it again no help by Joelle and
beef
[Applause]
[Music]
what a play by Trey young the Florida
that he has perfected and getting all
the love on the sideline no man he's
putting together a heck of a game
there's a tenth of a second to Collins
John will drive at bouncing Trey trapped
underneath
those to the corner plumps it
- swinging around on one there is John
Colin gives it back the tray nowhere to
go you get a bigger guy you then Fraser
switches on them on the baseline that's
a pretty easy floater their burger gets
it in Kevin looking long to the basket
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and beats the buzzer
then after two bounces three it falls in
and at LAN
Winston in overtime the basket is good